must be able to diam not Jemima Kish who
has bad code so I'm here during this
great session which is who are we on the
web about our identity about who we
pretend to be about our privacy about
our children about our relationships so
abroad abroad a big broad brushstroke in
in half an hour and so can I introduce
my hello who am i right here is Jamie
Bartlett author of a wonderful book
which I recommend called the darknet
which is the exploration of the furthest
most grim recesses of the internet quite
an extraordinary book I really do
recommend it and he is the director of
the centre of the for the analysis of
social media at demos so we have cory
doctorow
who we've already met today science
fiction writer half campaigner general
know-it-all very good man
eben kyndra and beeban kidron the film
and documentary maker who is filmed in
real life if he gets caught is that
right journalist from the bedrooms of
British teenagers to Silicon Valley and
examining the Internet's often
pernicious effects on children and here
in this beautiful coat is Beth Noveck
founder of the White House open
government initiative professor and
author of smart citizens smart state to
be published in November this year so
let's start with this it's my contention
and I think a lot of people's contention
that the web has changed us profoundly
in just 25 years could you start on that
Jane do you agree with that I think it's
changed certain people and it changes
people in very different ways it's easy
to make a sweeping generalization
especially that people are nasty or
meaner or when they're online the truth
is any way that we communicate any means
we use to change slightly the incentives
we have and the behavior that we
undertake and that's certainly true
where my contention is that there are a
small number of people who under those
conditions of the
behind the screen distant from the
people that they're speaking to do
engage in quite different types of
behavior they see a difference in their
online and their offline personalities
often for the worse
well they see very different types of I
suppose morality operating online and
off but they keep those two identities
separate and then there's a smaller
group within that for whom their online
identity starts encroaching into their
offline world and it fundamentally
changes what they think what they do and
what they believe I mean a profound
change of character yes for some people
people would you agree with that yes but
I think there's something that we always
miss out which is that we behave in
different circumstances very differently
you know it's about what circle of what
environment went in and the question is
always for me and because my interest is
in particularly young people is what is
the aggregate itself
how does and who is in charge of the
aggregate itself and can you know and
and are there formal ways in which your
behavior is dictated or nudged or pushed
that are structural above and beyond so
you know I think the best way that I
have of describing it is you know do you
you know as a young person do you want
yourself your immediate family or media
friends your school to determine your
reflection or do you want some
corporation to determine your reflection
I think that's that's the area I'm
interested in and that's the nuance of
who you are that we must get to do you
think there's any sort of profound truth
you can bring to us from America about
this about this lack or do you think
there is a change in people do you think
we've changed in the last 25 years of
course we've changed the point is
however it's not about whether the
Genet by itself has altered our genes
has altered our DNA in some way what it
does is it's a tool that allows us to
express ourselves it's an outlet so for
the narcissists who look into the lake
and see themselves and then go and post
a lot of pictures on Instagram it's one
thing but it also allows us to look into
that same Lake into the data lake if you
will and see reflected back to us what
we can do and what we know and that
allows us to use these tools to do a lot
of good in the world at the same time so
at just as we are on the one hand
focusing on the web and the net is an
outlet for narcissism and inward gazing
we also need to think about what it
allows us to do when we're out for
facing so down the street for example
there's a man named Mark Wilson he's a
neurosurgeon he works for the London
Ambulance core and what mark says is
that sitting next to you in the audience
probably somewhere next to you here
there is a paramedic there is a nurse
there's a doctor there's somebody with
CPR training so you know what he's doing
he's putting all those people on a
network he started this year he's got
5,000 registered medical professionals
signed up and what he can do is that
when somebody then has a trauma or an
accident they can rush to the aid of
somebody who's nearby and performed CPR
they can give them aid and assistance
faster than the traditional ambulance
could get to them and he's bringing this
peer-to-peer service to the London air
ambulance corps in order to increase and
improve the ability to deliver medical
services to people so what he does for
us as individuals it allows us to do
good in the world to express what we
know and to have an outlet for doing
good and for society allows us to tap
that potential and I think to tap that
expertise in ways that we haven't been
able to do before when we have relied
only on traditional institutions the
fascinating story that Corey what do you
think we talked on the phone the other
day you seem to think that actually it
would just it was simply amplifies
people's behavior there are already
people out there who are unpleasant is
that right well I mean I think it's true
that you know you can sometimes be
convinced that the person opposite you
on the internet would never say such a
terrible thing if they were face to face
to you but I I in my experience I've
found that oftentimes you get face to
face with them and they say exactly
thing so I think we've been oversold
networks disinhibition but also though
that we have a regression to the mean in
extreme network behaviors that when you
have a new tool come along people will
rush to it and find it engaging and
interesting in part by dint of its
novelty not because of what it does but
because it's never been done before and
then over time for a huge slice of the
population it ceases to have that sort
of really compelling nature so think
about you know the moral panic over
farmville when it appeared that like
playing skinner box games we're going to
destroy our society by sucking up all of
our all of our human hours and what it
turned out as you look at what's
happened to Zynga share price and user
engagement is that for huge tranches of
people farmville was briefly interesting
in the same way that if you go back 150
years and look at advertising it turns
out that 150 years ago you could sell a
lot of soap with a banner that said buy
our soap and you will be cleaned and
people became inured to it they regress
to the mean and so I think that we often
mistake that first blush with a
long-term effect we are drawn to things
that let us cooperate with one another
because that's the project of our
species right we started down our path
diverging from our hominid ancestors
when we began to labor collectively we
put a lot of energy into managing our
social relationships
not because we're narcissists and not
because we're shallow but because the
only way you can do something that
transcends one humans capability the
only way you can do something superhuman
is by working with other people and to
do that you have to keep track of other
people as well and so it's natural that
if you offer people a service that gives
them a bunch of social information
they'll engage with it deeply and the
problem is in engaging deeply with
social information about your colleagues
and peers and the people around you the
problem is that when it's commodified
and it's gamed by a firm that wants not
to help you maximize your happiness but
rather put you in a skinner box designed
to teach you to undervalue your privacy
that things turn out badly I think I'm
so very worried now that I'll never come
and the debate on this usually comes
down to net enthusiasts saying it's just
a reflection of what we do offline right
and then the other side saying no it's
making us nasty but I think that just
being a reflection doesn't quite capture
what's happening here because as I said
there are many people who are who find
certain types of negative behavior far
easier to do online than they would
offline and everything we know about bad
behavior whether it's accessing illegal
pornography consuming drugs whatever it
is if it's easier to do there's going to
be a slice of people who are going to do
it that wouldn't otherwise have done so
offline and that is I think what's
happening but also your book you have
really horrific journey into the dark
and there are people doing things who
would never have done those things
before I mean particularly the
pornography sites and the women who make
money in their little bedrooms doing
everything yeah I mean it's a kind of
horrible solipsistic world which
wouldn't it be possible before surely it
wouldn't have been possible or it would
have been far harder and there are
certainly a lot of people who access
illegal pornography who I think had it
not been that easy for them to find it
and unfortunately is far too easy to
access this stuff would not have got
sucked into that world and then that
fundamentally starts changing who they
are and the other side of this is how
easily you can become inert to this sort
of thing so when I spent a huge amount
of time in pro-anorexia and pro suicide
forums
I started off being shocked two days
later it didn't surprise me at all and
that is another great problem because
once you start becoming becoming a nerd
two things you can very quickly lose
your moral compass what do you feel
about that because I mean you you've
studied kids who have been seriously
affected by the web and not just the
exposure to pornography the idea they
got to be a bland no I think that I mean
on the kid thing I'm one of the things
that I have found really sort of
upsetting is that the last thing that
they develop as a sense
consequence so the idea that they are
acting in the present tense and that
they should imagine how that might be in
the future is a very problematic thing
it's like literally they do not have the
synapse is ready until they're in their
mid-twenties
I think what's difficult about this
subject is we always end up with that's
good it's bad of course it's both is it
is you know it makes it extreme and I
think that what you have to we just have
to ask is it neutral and I think that
everybody would agree it's not neutral
and so in what ways does the neutrality
push behavior because my favorite thing
at the moment is the pool party video
from Texas I'm sure everybody's seen it
with a policeman and so I imagine being
having an identity as a black kid in
Texas and then suddenly feeling the
power of taking on their authority and
getting rid of that guy which is
something that you can't do that's a
positive of course it is but that
doesn't mean that kids who are actually
in another context are not suffering so
it's not a good bad it's both and it's
not neutral how do we deal with that the
other thing I was wondering is if to
youth to win here do you think that
women have prospered on the web in the
first session we touched on this but it
was might have been a sort of engineered
male work world and that vast numbers of
programmers coders and designers are all
male do you think it's bad is it skewed
against women or do you think we can
change so that it is equal and more
balanced and fair attempted to make a
joke as the as a female scientist on the
panel I'm tend to start crying as well
as I do
but but as but I am the took an American
right you're he's Canadian so don't be
don't be fooled I'm right and we're the
and we're the Pollyannish out optimists
at all time so I'm always here to bring
the positive story so I think it's it's
you know to follow on this point
obviously there are the dangers there is
the dark side there are the bad things
happening but there are these examples
of good happening in the world and when
it comes to women and minorities and
underrepresented voices what you're
seeing is this medium these media as
giving as giving voice to people who
have not had voices before giving them
play outlets and places to talk giving
them ways of being represented I'm
thinking most recently now in the United
States of the black lives matters hash
tag where of course recent Pew survey
results show that among Internet users
African Americans are more than twice as
likely to use Twitter and more than
three times as likely to be posting on
Twitter on a daily basis and so black
lives matter becomes a hashtag and now
as a result police racism and police
reform becomes front and center on the
national agenda in the United States and
I think that is not an accident that
this is a medium that is as against the
traditional gatekeepers many of whom are
well shall we say white and male they
are finding a way to give expression to
their to new issues and to become part
of the public discourse in new ways but
also the same to be fair the same white
male gatekeepers are also finding new
and interesting outlets and innovative
ways of bringing content from new voices
and new people so it's a it's I think it
is both things at the same time but
giving voice in many ways to people who
haven't had a voice before and that
includes women among them you know I
think that it's important to remember
that deviant is not the same thing as
bad and spaces in which people can be
socially deviant or how behaviors become
socially normed and and on the one hand
we worry about it because we worry about
pro-ana becoming norming anorexia but on
the other hand if you think about
changes in rules about
while marriage excuse me the the way
that we equal marriage arose was because
people could outside of the remit of the
state and outside of the perfect
enforcement ability of the state
practice an illegal behavior that was
judged immoral and corrosive until
social acceptance was one right and one
of the things that you get in spaces
that can't be regulated or that are
difficult to regulate is a space in
which deviance can progress towards
normalness for good and for bad and
unless you think that your grandchildren
will look back on 2015 and say tell me
Gramps how did you have it so right in
2015 that none of our social attitudes
have changed you have to anticipate that
there's something that we're doing today
that our descendants will view as
barbaric in its restriction and the only
way that that is going to come to light
is if there are spaces in which people
can perform deviance without automatic
enforcement this is a question to all of
you do you think that we spend too much
time in or in this world what Susan
Greenfield ban has been for the
scientists also here suggests is a
two-dimensional world compared to the
wonderful colorful 3d world of our lives
do you people do you think we spent too
much time do you think we're getting
overloaded to over stimulated I think
there's an opportunity cost yeah and if
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit and
it's very attractive so it's much easier
you know for me to find out without posh
on BuzzFeed than it is to read a big
report on HS too you know and you could
say that's a better outcome for me but
you know so I think there's an
opportunity cost but I don't think it's
bad to spend time online it's simply a
question of how you expend and I would
like to answer the question about women
I think it's bad for body image and I
think it's really really bad for
learning about sex and particular
outcomes for teenager girls and boys but
primarily girls I don't think it's bad
for women as such and definitely we want
more women in tech
separate issue I certainly felt that I
was spending far too much time online
researching my book and I was getting
very very depressed and it wasn't just
because I was looking at you know
pro-ana sites and neo-nazis and internet
trolls partly it was that was very very
exciting it was thrilling it was
terrifying but it was very stimulating
and the naturally things in the real
world started to become a little bit
drab by comparison and I realized that
was part of the problem that you thought
I was constant and I know my story is a
particularly negative one because of the
research I've done and that's what I'm
here to talk about but I ended up
finding them you know I was always
looking for the next exciting thrill but
has been so stimulated by all of this
stuff that the offline world was was
coming to appear rather dull what's the
longest time you've spent off the web a
wave like not very long five minutes no
I mean that's why they made
transatlantic arrow voyages alright give
me twelve hour periods in which I don't
access the Internet but you know it
would be amazing if using the Internet
didn't change your brain because you
only have one thing you think with which
is your brain and using it changes it
and so climbing stairs changes your
brain it would be remarkable if using
the internet didn't change your brain in
some way but and it's also true that our
brains are finite where we can only pay
so much attention to so many things and
so it's also true that when you're right
there's an opportunity cost when you pay
attention to some things you can't pay
attention to others and also the things
that are novel can be quite compelling
but I want to bring back regression to
the mean right like the I think one of
the reasons that it feels like the
internet keeps getting more compelling
is because we're in an arms race between
our cognitive self defense mechanism and
and firms that would like to command our
attention right the reason the reason
things changed the reason we're not
still doing Friendster the reason it's
not still Usenet is because we had to
come up with more compelling offerings
because people ceased to be quite so
interested in the old ways not everybody
there's we we have a normal distribution
of
native capacity and preference but the
first you know the the first two Sigma's
sort of wandered off and into something
more interesting like I went to opens
open the side to the audience and is
there anyone got any questions quickly
yeah signal if you have and then we can
get a mic to you it's a broad subject so
Dan what about down here in the front
row you mean Mike super fast down front
who's spoken in the previous maybe just
say something about the neurobiology I
think Cory's right that you know people
have been writing letters to each other
in the time of John Keats you know there
were three posters a day and that got
people into all kinds of trouble in
Dangerous Liaisons has a suicide as a
result of social interaction so it's
nothing new in that Robin Dunbar has
done some very interesting stuff about
the evolution of the frontal cortex the
bit of the brain that sort of exploded
around the time that language evolved
and tool use evolved and social networks
were developed and it seems that about
120 is the number of people that you can
keep track of whether you're in a cave
in a village or online and so while
Cory's right that clearly our brains are
changed by all of our experiences
there's no evidence yet po che Susan
Greenfield that a fundamental shift is
happening in our brains and the number
of people we can keep track of what our
social network is cognitively seems to
be fairly fixed so I think we may be
overcooking the fundamental brain change
stuff what about the children you film
thanks Shirley was there any substantial
change in their behavior or do you just
just was its surface behaviour what do
you think was any kind of deeper change
I think there was a lot of compulsive
use and that actually that the big thing
for them was sort of the reward
technologies the stuff that is
deliberately there to extend use was the
biggest problem for them and it didn't
really matter whether it was texting you
know
I'm in Starbucks or watching porn or you
know or actually going back to a pro-ana
site you know it was the inability to
actually turn it off that they struggle
with the most well what about the idea
that they have now - you're gonna put
themselves out in the market as a sort
of little bland you know we all do that
to extent is that a problem when picture
of the growing up kids have always done
that it's just there's a much bigger
room you only use that to be queen of
your class and you have to be queen of a
bigger a bigger group it's it's a tough
gig it's more competitive if are they
more likely to be burned by this
experience or is he really just elderly
people fussing about it
I think we're fussing a bit too much
about the content and not enough about
the structure so that actually we should
concern ourselves more about these
issues of extended use compulsive use
how to get off how to sleep you know the
statistics on kids coming into school
without you know missing food missing
sleep or something it's it's big stuff
it's changing stuff so I think we should
be more concerned about that and a
little bit less concerned about some of
the content issues that we seem to get
bit hysterical about what about the
vanity that we're both adults and
children exhibiting do you think
anything about that Beth it seems to me
that we are all these little Ryan's sort
of brands or whatever it is and there is
a sort of ridiculous vanity about it is
a novel or do you find it perfectly
acceptable normal behavior for me it
seems extraordinary that people care so
much and what it displays imagine and
what people are they want to display so
much of their lives you know there is a
kind of sort of obsessive look at me
quality to the web widget you sound
healthy sure well some people call it
narcissism some people call it
transparency and it has it's it has
different boundaries I think for
different people and that kind of
sharing you know look I have a friend
who some of us share in common who is a
self-confessed oversharer on the web but
he tends to share about his medical
conditions he shares about the travails
that he's going through and that has a
lot of positive social benefit for some
people in other words that level of
sharing about his experience that's at
the root of services like patients like
me the participatory medicine movement
the idea that the greatest healing and
this is scientifically proven is going
to come not simply from the know-how you
get from the doctor but the know-how
that you get from other patients and
other sufferers so when people are
willing to put themselves out there in
different ways by sharing the
experiences that they've been through it
can have greatly beneficial social
effects for people at the same time it
may not be your vacation photos
that I so much want to see or know on
Twitter what you ate for breakfast but I
may actually want to hear about your
experience dealing with your school in
your local community or maybe I want to
hear about the disease or maybe I want
to know about the doctor you went to and
whether his or her bedside manner was
good or bad so that sharing is what is
at the root of the web and what's good
about it and so if it weren't for that
kind of sharing we wouldn't have people
and that innate sort of drive towards
collaboration that Corey talked about
that we wouldn't have people getting
online and crowdsourcing solutions to
problems it's why you have you know the
day after the Haiti earthquake hundreds
of volunteers going online to try to map
where the health care centers are and
doing that job which would otherwise
take years to do if done by one person
done in 24 hours and we're seeing that
again in crisis after crisis where
people are willing to give of their time
give of their know-how and share of
their personal experiences very much for
the benefit of others so I think it's
the minority of the content that we're
seeing that is the narcissistic what I
ate for breakfast stuff which is you
know one person's breakfast is another
person's treasure so we're gonna we
gonna pull the moment but not Darcis ISM
I think that often times when something
seems narcissistic or unimportant it's
because we're not the intended audience
right all of those important messages
that we all agree the web should be
there for it's cancer it's not cancer I
got the job I didn't get the job she
survived she died those messages are
only significant because they exist in a
in our kind of soup whose base is made
up of all of the seeming
insignificant moments that bind us
together socially so you know when my
wife gets up in the morning and I asked
how she slept it's not because I don't
know because we sleep next to each other
right it's a it's like the world's
easiest to decipher crypto it just means
like how are you I love you I'm thinking
about you right and so if it seems
trivial to you perhaps it wasn't
intended for you yeah it is often said
that people aren't as happy as they
appear on Facebook nor they as angry as
they appear on Twitter and we have a we
are performing we are performing to
certain types of audiences like now and
sometimes those audiences that we are
performing to for example in the pro-ana
communities are very very destructive
and dangerous ones but we get sucked
into the performance of being part of
that community and as I said for some
people that radically changes how they
behave very good point we're not unless
we have just one question okay let's get
the mic let's move with the mic here we
go the lady in the front of the blue be
nice to have a question I would just be
interested in how many personas each of
the panel members has online I have two
Twitter feeds one is my more normal one
the one is where I'm less favorable in
my opinions and that's probably because
I'm not brave enough to combine the two
but I was interested in whether the
panel had something I'll start with me
one well while researching my book about
500 but I'm now really only 100 so I
used to have a very active avatar in
Second Life and avatars in other virtual
worlds when one spent time in them and
now I have my own Twitter feed and I I
confessed I sometimes tweet for my kid I
mean I have different okto really so
there's the voice I use when I'm writing
fiction and nonfiction and writing for
the Guardian and writing for Electronic
Frontier Foundation those are all
different voices and they reflect
different aspects of who I am and in
terms of how many personas I have
overall well it's sort of one per email
correspondent really which is my major
way of communicating with people because
I certainly don't talk to my grand the
way I talk to my
friends and so of course I have
different personas and different facets
of my identity that I reflect the great
advantage for me of using email rather
than Facebook is there's no puppeteer at
the helm of of email who's got an
ideological commitment to collapsing all
the facets of your identity into one on
the grounds that if you have more than
one facet you are two-faced which is you
know a sociopathic view of the human
condition and one of the great reasons
to just use Facebook how many and I
started off with half a dozen and the
more and learnt about the net the less I
have so now have none no public ones
really does not even Twitter no nothing
hey commendable anyway thank you very
much